i was working on a bit about uh when i
played football when i left that field i
left everything on the field
my underwear my son
my bra
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola mis amigos
sport sporting paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
where you have [ __ ] weapons and you
know
i mean
that's a [ __ ] small place like this
yeah would you ever [ __ ]
point a gun at somebody i i i mean i'm
different than most people because
because of what i've done you know gun
safety i said
guy you don't [ __ ] around with
nothing so anytime somebody hands me a
gun
first thing you do
i don't care if he says he's checked it
first thing you do is check it if i was
[ __ ] rehearsing i would do it with my
[ __ ] hand
before i would [ __ ] point a gun at
somebody i would be like okay
here i am okay is this the right height
hold it closer
can't i can't get you and the
hold it up
but not yeah how's now can you see it
and then [ __ ] i mean there's a
hundred
videos of
guys
proving the theory wrong and and guys
who respect weapons there's there's no
there's a guy out there
some [ __ ] guy
are you recording yeah
oh yeah the the because
everybody has a [ __ ] job even in
independent movies like where there's no
money [ __ ]
safety first man [ __ ] i mean you we see
all these things happening that
they're accidents but they shouldn't be
accidents yeah it was no doubt it was an
accident the only thing that gets me
really
sick
is listening to alec baldwin said we
need to pass the law so
this doesn't happen again and we should
have law enforcement officers you know
here making everything don't blame it on
anybody else brother you know you're
part of it you got to own it you know
and and he
i'd hate to see
uh you have to own it one of the guys
that the not the broad that was in
charge of the guns but
her boss
somebody else is there he's already
lawyered up you know i ain't talking to
nobody no more yeah very smart thing to
do even the duty said was his friend the
director hasn't spoke spoken yeah
i think maybe just to the authorities
but in doing these shows he's done a
couple of shows interviews on television
and i said what the [ __ ] why is he doing
that you know he's an actor how do you
know if what he's saying
is true
if you've ever had to hire
a high-profile attorney
the first thing they do
is to tell you to stay off social media
stop talking to anybody stop answering
questions
stay off of your phone and let me do my
work because it's all legal
there's nothing that
there's not anything he can prove
or disprove or draw a picture or charts
like
some of our leaders [ __ ] take charts
there's internet sure [ __ ]
brings charts to a [ __ ] meeting
charts i i would
[ __ ] away just waiting for my [ __ ]
church to get here so we can get on with
the [ __ ] funeral i remember
uh
i had we had an officer involved
shooting in east ellie
and the guy had come out you know he'd
stab somebody come at people and without
charging the cops they were throwing big
big ass butcher knife thrown and now
he's just coming at him and they lit him
up he's gone
and sorry for him sorry for where i'm
not making light of the fact that we had
to take his life
so they're holding a public meeting on
it in the basement of saint alfonso's
church
so we're over there for this meeting and
gloria molina is going to be part of the
meeting
and so we got together with her staff
and her
and said do you want drawings here
lay layout lay out of the land and she
said
no
absolutely not no drawings okay so we
got that there and the local citizens
you're sure she didn't mean like
drawings like lottery like no
sir nobody wants to sit closer or
anything so she uh
she said no don't bring him so we didn't
bring him
and now the local citizens are getting
pissed off and they're calling us a
bunch
of lames you know we don't know what
we're doing badmouthing the cops
and
she comes up and she tells baca how come
you can bring the drawings
and baka comes up to me and he says why
didn't you bring the drawings i said she
said not to bring the drawings oh [ __ ]
and he says well that's not what she
said he starts getting in my and i
thought i was done because he starts
jumping in my ass
because i didn't have him
and i said hey look you want to get
pissed off at somebody
i said my boss is right over there
she confirmed that she didn't want him
here either she said no i follow her
lead
and so
he walks away and i said okay my [ __ ]
flaky i'm gone well then here comes
gloria
and gloria and i had gone to school
together wow and i've known her for
years was she tough in school no no not
like that at all matter of fact she's a
little cutie when she was in school yeah
she was the drill team
and so how come you think they call them
drill team because at that age everybody
in school
that's right they were all fine even if
they were little like a little gorditas
there's still something about the drill
outfit
so
she comes up to me
this job mo brat
bastard
i got a rash over
my ass
we're talking about
uh drilled the drill team and he was a
sheriff you know you know gil
he looks familiar gail uh was a girl he
went to vietnam
because they told him to get off the
streets yeah so they sent him to vietnam
yeah
hold the chair right here
i was hoping you didn't see that no no
thanks
gotcha thank you
one one year we lower we lower them the
next year we oil them
said that [ __ ] chair squeaks you guys
did it
um
do you live in denver no no i just had
the shirt but i saw you i saw you
remember sweat swag
yeah man good
what's going on you still have your
channel there at the
everybody knows you know dom right i
gotta tell you i don't know one year
you started in comedy were you trying to
sound like him i gotta tell you
something
i went he is the first comedian i ever
went to go see that i paid for
it
it was up in hollywood is it the laugh
factory or one of those yeah went there
i was with my wife and i love i laughed
my ass off one of the best he was not
clean then i don't know what he's doing
now but he was not gonna it was
but it wasn't it wasn't
it was funny and i laughed even more
because i had my wife who i call sister
mary clarence yeah you know i'm the
dirty one and it was the funny you were
the funniest thing free
and i never
the best i didn't know anything about
comedian now i you know you travel
around the u.s you know whatever you're
doing to entertain people i never got a
chance to see you again and i was so
excited about that it was kismet good to
see you good to see you you were meant
not to see them twice in your life
this when you went to nam yeah i went
all right you believe these guys
did you go to them no
i was i was back here
thanks 90 grand taking care of the
girlfriends the guys are over there
fighting
there you go i got it dear john from
from my girlfriend when i was over there
really oh she left you she left me she
dumped me like a bad ass cold when i
came out when i came out of the army
i had three goals i want to go to
college just because i didn't think any
nobody in my family had ever gone to
college
and
i knew i was mature because when i said
for my transcripts i obviously i was
embarrassed i thought dee stood for damn
good
and they let me in anyway because i was
a vietnam vet i wanted to become a cop
because it was a cop that saved my life
from the streets i wanted to give back
third thing i wanted to hook up with my
ex-girlfriend get her eaten out of the
palm of my hand
so i could break it off with her i
wanted revenge i wanted to see her
suffer i like that i remember that yeah
i got out in june
mental and i never forget
you became a sheriff with a d
out of high school
no the average
yeah
i mean no yeah i went to college after
that after high school you know they led
me into college because you went to
junior college junior college all right
they let me into juice there's
victoria's secret and then there's a
secret flea market
[ __ ] that
you put it all in your wife yeah you
know
get hold of the elastic right here oh
[ __ ] wrong with it already you're
liking the cargo
pre-war game used like jerseys all right
i went to high school i thought d stood
for damn good went in the arm went to
vietnam come back
i wanted to go to college so nobody in
my family none of my friends nobody
nobody i thought at that time college
was for real they want to go to junior
college well either one did you get the
associates i just i just thought that
was every door
higher education was for white rich
people
that's what i really thought i was young
naive i think you i think you were right
i started i started going
yeah then and i hooked up with my
girlfriend by i got out in june of 70 my
september i had her eating out of the
palm of my hand and the day after
christmas oh yeah we got married oh i
think they broke it yeah i thought i was
going to break that i've been married
forever yeah
this year this year dave chris will be
51 years you were vietnam age weren't
you
age maybe yeah but not mentality
here's what i told my brother joe
i'd be fighting right alongside of you
it wasn't for the fact that i have a
chemical imbalance
so i get very very neurotic when i'm
shot at
my hands get sweat you know hey man i
mean that [ __ ] happened
he said to me one that my brother he's
almost a general or some [ __ ]
and he said to me i don't know how you
do it like these little print planes in
like you know
10th seater going to a small town
you're talking about
you're getting shot at you're worried
about me getting turbulence you know
yeah
i wouldn't i don't know i mean duty
called
but uh they had to drive me to the
[ __ ] post office to register when
when i ran the hostages
everybody's like have you gone in i said
no i haven't gone there they're gonna
[ __ ] come and arrest you i said for
what we're not registered i mean you had
a time you had to in the register yeah
my number was too high
yeah you know
the guys that got like one to fifty were
grown a lot of guys you knew oh yeah
yeah a lot of guys said i begged one of
my best friends i said please
they're they're they the war is done
it's just like paperwork now don't do it
two weeks he was done he was done [ __ ]
it's tough man it's a tough one years
old it's tough how old is he 19. yeah
it was easy
i mean it's a real it's a real thing man
it's a it's a tough when you're young
and naive you know
you know
yeah nobody tried nobody told you not to
go i think your mother-in-law told you
to go no oh yeah my mother-in-law was
open
over there
what did you not until you so his
mother-in-law was like i don't know if
i'd like this guy
went to vietnam came back and she liked
them no you had to come back she didn't
like me till after i became a cop oh
once i became a cop then i turned into
migo
yeah
you know she had some
trouble on the other side of the family
you know there they had had conflicts
with the law so and i was just my wife
is three years older than i am so i was
just a young mukozo you know i wasn't
going gonna amount to anything
and then after i became a cop then i
became ego so gil was one of the
detectives who caught richard ramirez oh
jeez you know you leave your own you
capture your own people you let all
other white dudes go free huh
you couldn't been out there the [ __ ]
golden state killer the southland slaves
he didn't hit in l.a county he didn't
hit in l.a county let's make that you
know mexicans would be serial killers if
they wouldn't like use our weight you
know the the manteca murderer because he
leaves like grease
it was a bag with money and the greasy
bag paper bag there was one guy on his
serial code he was saying that he was
talking about his life and his crimes he
said he was going upstairs to his
apartment and a couple was coming down
he had he had a head in
his bowling bag and this couple was
walking down holding hands and he said i
was so incredible that the distance was
two feet away that he had miles away and
like what's going on in your life i mean
who has a you know a head in the right
bowling bag right i mean
it's another i was you know the
alexander hotel the cecil hotel
all that [ __ ] that oh yeah um they're
just getting ready to open up the
seasonal hotel again
they just it was on the news today
listen the ceo of the cesar hotel the
cecil hotel is where they found that
woman in the water tank i mean then
somebody said we always talk about
murders and
all right here we go but they found her
in the tank she was staying there she
was from vancouver she was looking for a
place to stay that was cheap she stayed
at the seesaw and then she was like
imbalanced i think that bipolar and then
full of dope too but but yeah and then
that hotel became notorious for
when they started looking into it people
staying there they were from way way
back so
uh it was the cecil hotel cecil
which ramirez stayed there
and a lot of other people stayed there
people jumped out they threw people out
of the window and stuff and then now
it's called
as if the name
stay on main
was it here yeah it's in l.a
so forget about
all the [ __ ] ghouls and [ __ ] that are
gonna be in there and turn on the water
it's gray
stay on main yeah they put a sign over
the other side that's like that bathroom
that commercial brother bathroom where
you have a [ __ ] moldy bathroom and
they come in and they just put a plastic
[ __ ] little thing that fits around
your thing over the mold
that'll be healthy the gross chick
growing in there
um did you see those people this week
from that those terrible tornadoes yeah
the ones that survived because they're
the bathtubs
oh they were the bathtubs
and then the house was the levels
it's unbelievable you know is that i
think is that uh
uh climate change i mean
they were blowing through the whole
midwest like you don't see [ __ ] like
when you don't see [ __ ] like
like that
we have near philly this year and philly
too you're never you're never gonna go
in that far east what's more shocking uh
a tornado in philly or a gambling
downtown in philly gambling downtown
that's a serious
gambling right there's a casino in
downtown would anybody guess that you
were from philly or do they guess that
you're from jersey or
for well i always auditioned for this
special
cinemax special when i first started out
the guy said to me goes
i'm not i got to pass on you you said
you're too new york you know you got the
new york attitude you got the look the
whole the sound of your accent i go from
philly he just walks away
and he's all philly like it's he's not
he's not trying to be new york jersey
boston uh [ __ ] he's he's all philly oh
yeah
um
e-a-g-l-e-s
yeah where were you where were you
when
the eagles won the super bowl
uh the last one let's get the two years
ago
party there it was so funny because the
patriots i mean it feels as crazy as
boston is
talk about white trash god love them i
mean i love the people up there but my
own as they say
and the only fight was patriarchs fans
yeah you know yeah i've seen philly
people do crazy stuff you know yeah yeah
the the the
good team they had
were you mcnabb were you
back in those days no well i knew that
that team i liked but when i was a kid
we had like a competition with boston
and basketball was the big thing in my
neighborhood and we wanted
all we wanted was the
celtics or
or sixers to be to be the lakers
that was big at the spell you went to
the spectrum yeah
and i mean you see people that why would
you do this why would you go into like
one of the with their uniform or were
you uniformed you know right i think
some guy would have a
laker thing or something thing they beat
the [ __ ] out of it
that's what they did i saw i was at the
i was at a monday night game at the
coliseum
and it was the raiders and the rangers
they still play and there was a guy that
went up with a hat with the bolts on the
side
and he comes down he's got a foam finger
number one charger finger
a dude gets up from behind him pushes
him from behind a guy goes flying down
the stairs and then everybody's up
cheering and the same game these two
dude these two guys are holding this
sheet and it says you know raiders
monday night football and if you look
close at the sheet it said property of
valley county jail
one of the best [ __ ] things i've ever
seen man yeah they were right behind me
i said check out what it says on the
sheet property l.a county jail but those
like we didn't have football in l.a for
25 [ __ ] years nobody cared now
there's two teams yeah uh
you're trying to make
you say that you know property valley
county jail went to a dodger game and
some fans were [ __ ] up and everybody
started calling for security come down
here and they they got him they hooked
him up and they're saying yeah get him
out of here get a matter a couple of
mexicans lit up he says [ __ ] there's
overcrowding the jails let him go let
him go
how about that
man i was working on a bit about uh when
i played football when i left that field
i left everything on the field
my underwear my son
my bra
[Laughter]
i said that to tom papa i guess it's
kind of predictable i go well i'm sorry
i'm doing my [ __ ] best
did you uh were you uh i mean i i love
dr jay i mean i love that yeah that was
the best
for me the 83 sixers were the best team
yeah watching them that was incredible
was it last year that one year it was a
perfect season yeah that year that dr j
that last year where he was he was
incredible then he cut his fro
and uh he had his knee braces on
the but he was still i mean one of the
best oh yeah oh yeah
the kids today are better than ever i
mean a lot of them can do what he did
but you know it's just like in comedy
you know
you know we see guys and we pattern
ourselves a little subconsciously after
them that's what people yeah especially
with his moves he's coming between his
legs backwards and throw it up there
geez i don't know his hands are so big
he could pick up an a a record album
yeah
uh i mean uh he played in the aba before
that's where he was at his physical peak
yeah three-time npp i think something do
you remember the aba there's a
documentary they had a name like the
squires which were like pimps i think
squires they had uh [ __ ] guys that
were out of control leather you know
long leather coats they all had i think
goatees they're all in the early 70s
often you know they're all [ __ ]
chicks and bikinis the red white and
blue uh basketball i love the ball the
ball that was awesome yeah
and then and by god and then i think a
couple of guys were they from philly the
two guys that
said
if you buy our team you have to pay us
for the
in the entirety of the nba like
somebody bought the team i'll see if i
can find out from these two guys and
they
make money philly was it yeah i just
wanted there were aba owners that well
trump up early on today um
the usfl i think was
i went to usfl games really did you guys
have one billy uh yeah i think we had
one and uh
herschel walker was like the big star in
that league yeah yeah
he's an animal jesus oh great athlete
yeah he was incredible it could be the
best one of the best running backs
hard right
politically
herschel walker
and a son that's uh um
very vocal after he stood hard right
after he got out of football yeah yeah
yeah
the usfl i think steve young played for
the yes steve uncle's in that league he
was in that league play the la express
and then there was the [ __ ]
california sun from another league that
they had
anthony davis who went to san fernando
high went to went to usc
played for
uh i got a football autograph ied you
know the worst part about anthony davis
is uh on top so his sister cynthia was
in my junior high class and she forgot
her track shoes
and she said my brother's going to bring
my track shoes and he said let's see
convertible rolls-royce
in college gets out she runs out there
he waves to us in the winter he gets in
his convertible rolls-royce he's in
college and drives off all right that's
pretty balanced
the lakers the great running back eric
dickerson yeah
yeah he they were interviewing him and
he i loved it she he said
they had a corvette it's a silver brand
new corvette and where'd you get that my
grandmother gave it to me
yeah they all had grandma's
when he said it i love the fact that you
could tell he was lying
[ __ ] those guys they shut them all down
i think that
they said eric dickerson had checks he
hadn't he hadn't cast yet oh yeah coming
from uh
they had a they had a white running back
that cut that
time rick james i think his name yeah he
split time with dickerson can you
imagine you have to bring in a fresh
half back every other player that guy
right yeah craig pony express smu
wow
they have one white kid on one of the
teams that
uh i forget his father played in the nfl
yeah that's jeffrey nice
and they and they they never mentioned
it because like it's like it's not not
bad thing it's a good thing you know it
was like
all the great running backs were white
right i mean they were black yeah and he
was the only one nobody ever says
where'd this kid come from right i mean
that uh
whenever a white dude could run really
fast oh yeah i think you automatically
did he go to the nfl did like
those dudes some of those dudes could
could really i mean they were chased
when they were kids dumb dumb bb i was
at the first
rose bowl
when leonlette was running
he recovered the fumble it was running
right in front of us
and he didn't realize that dom bibi with
that big ass helmet was running behind
him
hadn't given up
hit the ball under right you go and he
was like this guy and he knocked it out
of his hand but he didn't see that guy
run down probably maybe 60 yards in a
full sprint and caught his eye caught
his eye he was celebrating before he got
to the end zone
i was thinking about this might be a
joke actually my friend of mine said to
me that uh he's a basketball coach he
says i got some really good black kids
because they compete with the really
good black kids on the other team and he
said but if i said that i'd get fired i
said what do you say he says well i say
that they're good athletes that's the
key word athlete they don't save race
and i said to him about two weeks later
again who how's he's playing towson
state i go are they any good he goes
they're very athletic
i said
how athletic he went very uh
i said so even the even the manager
the medical manager could dunk you know
yeah
very athletically
they're all good they're all good
they're all good but they they uh
i mean we had a guy that was at our
school
uh
i think his name is if i use anybody's
name kenny griffith
had a 36 inch vertical jump wow damn i
mean he looks like a deer
just when it gets scared yeah
he in 11th grade
i mean just a specimen
colleges come they realize he has 34
credits you need 162 to pass
as a as a senior he had 34 credits i
don't know how the [ __ ] it's like one
year of one year
and they all went away
it's only 33 inches higher than mine
i mean imagine man that could you see
the [ __ ] jump
yeah barclay was an old friend of mine
charles barkley and he had his his
thighs were like
32 inches
his other sides were like the same as a
lot of people said his their uh
waist and if you know
charles barkley was was thick or fat
if you look at him back then
oh you know not so much
he wasn't he wasn't that round no not at
all i just love listening to him and
shaq get together and rip each other up
yeah they they seem to settle down a
little yeah the first charles seemed
like it was territorial most but then he
realized shaq was coming
now that he's been pretty good i mean
barclay is he's comedian funny yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's just funny
he's hilarious yeah there's a lot of
when i had my talk show he was uh the
year before the new year's he had gotten
arrested you know
so you know he sat down and i said uh i
know what you did last new year's eve
what are you doing this new year
that dude sheriff joe put him in the
mail for like a week oh that's our
problem
uh big jumpsuit yeah the only thing that
really embarrassed him that was when he
spit on the little girl
yeah because the guy he was spitting on
a guy
that's good but the little girl got it i
mean he was really
really sad that he did that yeah he's a
good dude i mean dude
loves too i don't really i don't gamble
much myself but uh
charles is oh yeah he's a huge
notoriously
big guy nobody nobody buys a drink he
buys every drink he's very good heart
you know yeah he took my mother to see
uh like
glenn campbell or one of those guys that
i would never go see
because she liked him and i guess he was
playing golf with him
that's awesome it looked hilarious me
him my little mother
[Laughter]
mandingo he's walking around
protecting her
what's your uh what is your
you still do the the i was not talking
about the left factory channel do you
still do that oh the uh yeah
it's going pretty well that's pretty
good
yeah that i know maybe i can get you in
there absolutely
um what
is it from the is the lab factory
channel or how do people see it uh
i don't know
it's it's uh my girl's here she knows
yeah but i mean you've had tamarra live
from the left factory yeah i'm a real
life on the line i'll do it you do this
i'll do that for you i appreciate it
yeah yeah we have a lot of fun i i had
one episode with bill burr and jamie and
bear rejected jamie said he wasn't ready
yet he's because he said you were the
inspiration for me to go back to new
york to come back here a better comedian
wow but he goes and bill was saying that
he he was so pissed that he wanted to
rip the chair off behind him you know he
just wanted he said here's this guy
talking to me
accent country we think he's farsi we're
not sure he
you know a lot of people they said
listen you got to lose the mexican
people
he was mexican all of a sudden
yeah he uh you know i used to see you on
stage i was thinking this guy's [ __ ]
good i'm thinking how's that he how is
he not making it and next next week
later you shot you shot up well man you
know we've known each other a long
time i saw you in denver a couple years
ago i mean we've been friends a long
time yeah that's so exciting about
having you in here oh thank you i
remember a joke i'm not sure if it's
funny man
that
it was early 90s you said you saw
arsenio in a gym
and he was wearing a cape yeah yeah and
then you said hey take care of yourself
and he said you take care of yourself
was that was that the punchline i don't
remember but you you where you arriving
yeah he had a cape because i went to the
gym and i saw a senior there and he was
wearing a cape
at the gym right yeah yeah he said hang
in there i said you hang in there
you're wearing a cake to the cape to the
gym oh my god how about that i remember
that [ __ ]
that was that's 30 [ __ ] 30 what year
did you start
doing stand up in hollywood uh in
hollywood 83. yeah that's that and in
philly though how do you start in philly
where did you i didn't start in philly i
started in new york um oh i did do one
gig in philly and i was and i bombed and
they were talking and stuff and i got i
got really mad and i said i'll be back
you [ __ ] i was like some kind of
like that was a general patton all of a
sudden you know
but i i always said the thing i i i shot
to the middle and i and i landed there
you know i
don't know what to do but it's been a
fun career yeah absolutely i'm not
retiring today no no
i'm not worried you were the funniest
man that i had ever heard and it had to
be in the mid 80s and i still don't know
to this day i'm talking to the wife
i don't know what i was doing because i
never went to hollywood you know i
wasn't a hollywood type guy and i was
already working homicide
and so i don't know if we went out for a
dinner and i don't know why i'd go to
hollywood was it the comedy store most
likely most likely
uh and
i remember watching when you came out
and i thought this man is the funniest
guy in the world thanks you know there's
the thing about stand up is there's no
best you know like like the hot the 100
yard dash it's like
you can't say that the guy came in
fourth is really faster
right the first guy came in first that's
it right like for stand up you know he's
just he was just good i don't get that
sammy muddling show but he's as good as
anybody oh it's just it's just taste at
that point at that point in time
before i came on this show
uh
by invitation of george
i had i told him i'd paid at least five
times to go see him you know before i i
just i love people come twice but
[ __ ] you kept coming back i kept
coming back uh louis anderson yeah i saw
louis anderson i was back in washington
dc i had been speaking at the fbi and i
had a friend back there picked me up and
we went to
the comedy store over there we went to
see louie anderson
and i had
the lady that i was with
she had money they all knew her oh come
on
front row seats right there and her
instructions were don't let the ice at
the bottom of the glass they just kept
bringing the [ __ ] over no ma'am louie
anderson was it i don't know if i went
to front row
he could fall on you oh i know
so louie was a headline
and i'm laughing and this lady that i'm
with
she's just as loud as i am and laughing
and when the show was over
he came over and said hello and thank
you you know you guys are really great
and you know i'm doing another show next
i said i'm sorry
i'm not here you know i'm from l.a she
lives here i'm back i'm back in l.a well
i'll be out there in two weeks god i'll
give you all the tickets you want would
you come and see the other show just
because my laughter was loud i just love
comedy i love to laugh and that's why
uh mr lopez here
he keeps me laughing did you wha what
kind of a policeman were you
i i was a regular
guy did patrol work all the all that
other stuff but a sheriff though 38 yeah
38 years of the los angeles county
sheriff's department 26 out of those 38
was working murders
i always think of like being a cops one
of the hardest things has to be going
going to the club the car when you can't
see who's in there you know you pull
them over and you pull in front of them
and then you got to make that walk
because anybody can just lean out boom
you know
you know you try
all i can say is they they train you
they try to prepare you
for all that stuff you know certainly
they can anybody can have you anytime
they really wanted to
uh i think the the
the scariest part of
police work was
when all of a sudden when you're out on
patrol and you pull your gun on somebody
and they don't give a [ __ ] if you have
the gun or not you know
you know go ahead shoot me you know come
on what are you what are you gonna do
you know or passive why are you doing
that you know i'm not doing it now i'm
really because if somebody pointed a gun
at me
i'd be [ __ ] in my pants
and so if that doesn't
cause fear and they're not gonna do what
you said
well it's time really get ready because
he's got a gun on him you're gonna you
know there's gonna be a shootout or just
keep your eyes and then the last minute
put it down and then you're just in for
a good fight where did the police tape
show up
what year did they start using police
tape because before that's hilarious
they didn't have tape before yeah people
could just walk like like crime scene
tape yeah crime [ __ ]
yeah he's he's dead and you're [ __ ]
walking in the [ __ ] ball but [ __ ] i
got [ __ ] blood on my [ __ ] shoes
mid 70s grab that stick right there what
the [ __ ] i mean late 70s
let's say well you had to protect the
[ __ ] scene right yeah late 70s is
when it came out and i'll never forget
because we put what did they use before
they put they didn't have [ __ ] before
festival seating
and we had it and they they had to start
signing people want to go in there and
then you sign okay why are you going in
there sign right here i don't care your
cop or not you had to sign the
lid the log and we had tape around it
and i remember i had a lieutenant you
know who's the watch commander he's the
boss
and we've got the tape around and he
says okay i'm gonna go and take a look
inside i said well hey you want to sign
this before you go in there because
that's what's going there now
and he looked at me says
did i remind you that you're a deputy
and i'm a lieutenant and i'm the watch
commander here i don't sign [ __ ] and i
do what i want and he walked in
and i was okay well right here comes and
that's probably the day that i knew i
want to be a homicide cop because we
respected the homicide cops homicide guy
comes in there and he says
hey young man hi barrett fitzgerald but
everybody called me fitch just call me
fetz i said yes sir my name's gail
carrillo and he says no sir i said call
me fitz
and he said okay he said wait hold that
thought he says who is that over there
in the crime scene
and i i looked it right so well that's
my watch commander
sir and he says i told you not sir my
name is fitz
he says what's he doing over there i
said i don't know i asked him to sign
the log sheet he reminded me of my
position and his position wow you know
he did he says hold that thought i'll be
right back
he walked in there he was a sergeant
this guy was lieutenant the watch
planner he walked up he says
good evening lieutenant and he says
good evening
and he stuck his hand out there he says
sergeant barrett fitzgerald
and but he didn't stick his hand out to
shake
the lieutenant suga's anna bear fish
cheryl didn't he says
uh before we waste our time here he says
i need to ask you what are you doing
inside here he said i just want to come
take a look at the body see what's going
he said would you mind doing a favor he
said how about taking a look from the
outside of that tape
this is my crime scene
and he stomped off got in his car and
took off and i said
that's what i want to do
i want to be well barry fitzgerald was
actually an actor too i was amazing
he sounded like nobody ever stands in
ireland well at the top of the day
tipping medical out of here
they sound like that
there is no not there not it's
exaggerated here
i mean you think you can find that
accent but that's like one italian guy
going hey are you
here
um did you uh where were you when rocky
came out
i was just moving up to new york oh was
it big in philly it had to be oh huge
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] the fact that we the
state they showed the art museum and it
was beautiful
that's not the real philly that's not
the i mean some of it
my grandparents had a had a bakery on
that where he runs yeah yeah it's 9th
street yeah was that that was like the
the kind of like um
like a mart like a food market yeah or
thing down there
was it was that
in philly or outside of it or it was
right in heart south yeah [ __ ] remember
that [ __ ] that was running yeah is that
where they had the
beef processing plant okay you know he
gets in there he trains with them
they'll slap a cow amazing that's where
i was checking
where were you i was working security
for them for the movie
at the sports arena yeah
sly stallone came up to me i had met him
one once before and he comes to me and
goes hi dumb i'm sorry i'm sly like he's
saying his name said oh i'm thinking of
me like he's just he's just being polite
i'm thinking
i said you're telling me who you are
you're not like rocco rocky but you
rambo too how did you do that how do you
pull that off
he was a nice guy he treated us really
nice
he was very very nice and i remember
i wanted uh one of his pictures
autographed take home to the wife at the
end of the day
and he says gil come see me tomorrow i
ran out of them here today so i got one
from carl withers
nice who was
apollo creed of course i got it from
apollo creed and i got home that night
and i said hey i got an autograph for
you and she goes oh she's all excited my
wife and i said here it's just i didn't
want apollo's autograph i wanted rocky
it'd be pretty amazing man what a great
what a [ __ ] great movie and and he
said
i'm playing like who do you think is
going to play rocky because yeah
i want to play rocky they talk to
ryan o'neal they're talking to a bunch
of different guys he's like well nobody
knows who you are
and he's like well that's that's kind of
a packaging thing
and he held out yeah he [ __ ] held out
they could have given the money he could
have uh taken the money for the script
they would have done it and he said i'm
i'm i'm that guy
i remember
he got down to his bottom dollar to the
point where like he had to
like get rid of his dog like sell him he
couldn't afford and then as soon as
either rocky sold or he got his first
paycheck from him got the dog back but
like that's how down and out he was
before and he was still sticking to his
guns like if i'm not in this then you
don't get it like one of the best movies
ever yeah i loved it i watched all of
them
rocky
scarface
[Laughter]
rocky i mean he's one of the funniest
if you took scarface as a kind of
semi-comedy you really enjoyed it
wasn't that the best your [ __ ] womb
her womb was so polluted you can't even
have a baby
did somebody say that
yeah
[ __ ] crazy i dated her one time
so polluted
but that's you know those things when
you see him and then you know it's funny
how his career
as the rocky movies went like the second
one
and then
which is when we where he
was training in the mansion and he had
the [ __ ] robots and he was all that
[ __ ] that he was he was uh like on the
way up it may have been three three
maybe three
where he changed they said that one day
that stallone looked at himself i think
he might have been on wilshire and
he saw his reflection in his car
in the mirror of um wilshire and he go
he goes i look like a [ __ ]
douche i didn't realize i was a douche
people that told me i was becoming a
dude she goes not until i looked over
and saw my car
and my reflection of the car i realized
you know what i look like a [ __ ]
douche in the store which you know
god forbid you know success makes you a
douche but it it depends how you handle
it yeah the easiest thing to what
happened right yeah one of the best
voices ever
one of the st uh arnold schwarzenegger
again didn't speak english
star
uh stallone
low budget movie
one of the greatest
you never know what people know i was
playing basketball george clooney we
still played
where are
about the game there
and he comes up to me one day he wasn't
he was not he's a very funny guy he's
not real serious he says can i talk to
you for a second
i said yeah what's up he goes i left
roseanne
what do you think i said
yeah he said it was number one show at
the time yeah i said yeah george you'll
get so you'll get something better
believe me
and i'm just trying to make him feel
good where did he get something back
right because you know he was uh george
clooney was roseanne's boss
on roseanne i was trying to think like
is that right
i didn't even know he played the boss
early on he did like 50 pilots he was
like ridiculous
i know before he didn't just step on the
biggest stage at all you know he hit it
tough
i mean
and you look at what happened i mean
just
yeah it worked for him
did you hear he gave like each of his
friends a million dollars isn't that
cool yeah pretty amazing yeah pretty
amazing they still do like i just we
just saw him with
grant the guy that runs his company and
a couple other dudes golfing and he
doesn't really
he doesn't really uh golf much but i
think for the guys he goes out
uh a couple of times and uh well he was
it wasn't terrible but he was he didn't
understand basketball and his whole idea
was just run the guy over
he got hurt he got hurt and the guy
would get out he said he can't do that
it's not rugby you know oh i'm trying i
said you can't interview he didn't know
basketball he didn't know yeah he i mean
he's not a terrible athlete but he just
didn't know the game you know right you
can't you can't get the ball and just
run run over right right right that's
what we played in
in high school i think
you know things are all very different
now
i didn't play
any kind of basketball i'd never heard
of kareem abdul gonzalez so his
basketball was not a big deal
well you were from here right yeah i
didn't play uh basketball you watch the
lakers or anything no
no
basketball wasn't a big sport for me
baseball and football that was it
the uh
dr bus you know the late sure great guy
bought the lakers and they're going to
do a 10-part
series on
on hbo of showtime yeah the lakers of
that era
did you ever go to any games yeah i went
with the manager just because he had
tickets at lake right
we we sat right down right on the floor
some games not over again but that was
pretty cool right near lakers bench
amazing right at the in the forum back
then
there was one point where they had the
four of the number one draft league
number drafts and then and
they're stable that's incredible amazing
i went there
the year that dr j won
we saw a game
at the way on the top
at the forum and you know the lakers
lost
and uh
so i saw dr jake play i think that was
the only time i saw him play
and they won that year that eighty-three
was 83 83 that they won the championship
but
you know um
seeing uh i mean i saw will chamberlain
in a stutz bearcat off the 405 one time
in the morning
coming up like going over the hill
coming from the valley over my [ __ ]
world chamberlain like 8 30 in the
morning we're honking said there's a
little difference he went like this to
us oh
hang loose he went to my my mother's
high school
brook high school and really yeah he
talked about being with 1200 women
nice thing one time my mom was one of
them
i think john witherspoon said that you
know it goes if he did that many he'd
have to be brushing his teeth and he'd
go like this you know yeah yeah he'd be
making cooking breakfast and he's like
he had to be doing it all 24 hours a day
for like 22 years to to do what he's
doing the numbers
yeah yeah you were in hollywood chopin
yeah yeah yeah remember hollywood
shuffle great movie no i didn't see that
one yeah hollywood shuffle was about the
almost like um
man powerful movie about
white kids getting a break and working
hard and it was really good yeah but it
was funny too you know it was funny and
uh look it up a lot of yeah it's a great
one um what what do you think what
happened to robert townsend that i you
know he did a couple more movies and
then i i never see him i haven't seen
him in years and then i was hoping to
keep that cast together for a while i
thought it was a good ensemble
absolutely yeah yeah who was everybody
was in that keenan and damon were in it
and uh
yeah john was funny it's one of those
it's one of those movies where if you
look at it
you say
everybody's a star in this movie
like everybody
went on to be known which is [ __ ]
almost impossible yeah i always got
italian parts obviously you know so i
wanted to play this gay guy that i knew
from from college it was really fun but
he had this laugh he go
he closed his mouth
and i just thought he was so funny and i
got a chance to play in my words you're
tearing the words out of my heart right
right i remember that's right that's
right
man what and they did that here in l.a
yeah and
we'd have to stop shooting because
robert ran out of money and he'd go on
the road to get get a couple a couple
thousand bucks and we'd start again like
that would they do that movie for dumps
not even a million dollars maybe huh oh
no not even
so i looked up on wikipedia a hundred
thousand dollars estimated
yeah and you're listed as an uncredited
writer too no i know i don't know well i
guess that's like we a lot of us
improvised i guess they can't sue us i
don't know i saw that it was in there
but also that's a movie that
has it been 40 years
uh well no way 87 so close
35.
what the [ __ ] man i would think i have
to have more material by now
no i mean
still a hollywood show
yeah you're still hungry shuffle okay
that's
it's like being a maid man
so you're not italian i am completely
yeah yeah yeah
and that thing where they test your
genealogy right i was like 93 italian
and then a little bit of cypress little
greek and a little northern italy so
basically a grease ball
yeah yeah i know no [ __ ] about that
because that was the
did you do your genealogy no
no i haven't done it
they've asked me to do that i don't want
to know [ __ ] about where i came from i
don't care and i know there's got to be
somebody dirty in my family and i'm
going to do it well i'll tell you what
happened you don't see a lot of 23andme
[ __ ]
commercials anymore because they realize
that when you do that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
police
have access to it yeah and they started
plugging in [ __ ] people into the
their data
and finding they've made cases is it
golden state i think we've even talked
about that here it was golden state was
made like that and then so is the
the uh
the the grim sleeper the grim
the grim sleeper is that what they call
them the grocery with black guy that we
used were lapd mechanic they did him
they made his
through blood it was first his son and
then yeah then they could even like
connect the dots around you how are you
and philly and then how what what who
who did you see that made you want to be
a comedian and who did you tell and who
like did you a buddy go with you that
first time or the fourth yeah the first
time i punked out i was went to the
improv and we went down the village to
start drinking and i was really pushing
the time so by the time i got there was
done
but then when i finally did it um i
don't know i got lucky with this one guy
when he let me emcee and and i would
improvise in between acts and
that's how how about you you start here
you know what i started here i started
at the comedy store in westwood right
and then i was kind of doing it in 79
80s once in a while
and then around
83 i started emceeing at the ice house
and i think that that did it that did it
because me too you in between guys you
could be funny but you weren't going to
get
uh spots i don't think right now i'm
like you couldn't get better
five minutes at a time or ten minutes at
a time but emceeing
you could work on
introductions
you could
ask the crowd to do stuff then you could
throw a line in there throw another one
so you could you could hit you could
score but also you were getting your
legs and your [ __ ] chops so when you
started to do
your time you could do more time because
you were just doing little pieces
instead of a guy up there for like 12
minutes or whatever they would give you
and people would be going like this
[ __ ] man it's i could not you
i've never seen you have anything but
strong sets all the time you were
playing attacks yeah it was like machine
gun
that's a cool feeling when you can get
it down like that [ __ ]
you do that tonight show too with johnny
carson yeah i would who saw you jim
mccauley you know and this guy says to
me uh
he said to me when he booked me and i'm
behind the curtain he goes have fun i go
fun this is [ __ ] freaking this is
terrible
you know all i could think of was
passing out the spitting up anything you
know it was fine but i was just glad it
was over how long ago before when did he
see you and then how long till you did
it he only saw me once because i didn't
know he was in the room right the girl
he was always flirting with the
waitresses at the improv and i was
friends with them and they liked my act
and they would come in when you know not
it was pretty empty
and i come on stage when he goes uh good
grades said i said thanks he says you
want to do tonight's show i go nah
i said of course i want to do this nice
thing
and that's how i got it by the girls
more than wow because i
one thing i wasn't nervous at all
because i didn't know he was in the room
right you know you know how people would
get um
the same the regulars said
they lost all the funny because they
they were still worried about it i mean
that guy was the most guy jim mccall he
was the most powerful guy in comedy yeah
because it was like the impermanent or
if you get to pass that stamp did you
ever deal with carson
i did it november of
91 six months before he was going to
leave around because you're pretty young
yeah and and then uh um
bill cosby
uh bumped me
and then
they thought once you got bumped you do
what you were doing like you know a lot
of guys got bumped and never
went back and then i think the next week
they called me and said you know we got
we got you a date like almost like
within two weeks of the office they
really wanted you yeah let me get them
bumped yeah
i did okay again
the [ __ ] scary and
rodney's thing helped me the most
because i was very relaxed by then the
one that uh oh yeah young comedian
special there's there's no uh today
the specials aren't even special anymore
now right but in those days it was only
like hbo
and maybe robert klein or one of those
guys would have one because they're a
friend of the hbo guys but everybody has
specials now i know
back then roddy dangerfield had a club
um
and he would do the young comedian
special and he would bring on like who
is a dice
roseanne jose yeah jim carrey oh my god
he said to me i got to i got real close
to him for the last couple years of his
life and
dangerfield was such a character
and he said to me i said uh you know can
i get you anything because no no can i
do anything for you kid i said you know
one thing
could you close your robe
remember when we're eating he goes
i'm trying to eat i see those little
purple balls of yours please i said just
he never left he went you're funny
he would uh he would go to the club
with a robot
yeah
and
in in some part of the set the rope
would would open
oh jeez
and he's wearing just the ropes
yeah he'd be doing coke and
it was crazy i mean when he was 75
he uh i saw him down he was getting his
birthday party and i saw him down at the
comedy magic club
and he said he was at his party invited
him he goes
you want to go get [ __ ] up kid i don't
know i don't do drugs or anything
he says i'll be back in 10 minutes don't
don't leave you know
he did it at his 80th birthday too [ __ ]
man he was he was he's tough
he went at it man he went at it he was
funny though he was
one of the i when i was at bally's i
think
what was i doing you just never got any
respect i was gonna say do you think he
got enough by the end
you know i saw recently uh don rickles
on an old andy griffith show he was
hilarious oh man that's right
he played uh like a like uh
like a con man or something yeah you
remember that episode yeah
he had the little suit on he was like
and i think they let him leave town
without embarrassing without
embarrassing himself he kind of he
couldn't do anything right yeah so he
didn't he didn't paint andy's house
right but andy said he painted it so he
could leave wow a little dignity right
he was really fine i'm sitting here in
front of two icons but you know who
the funniest man i've ever seen and he's
no longer with foster brooks who was
always in character he was funny yeah
the just being the drunk and that was
roast
oh the rose
the and i still watch them today i pull
them up and the ropes were blue but they
cut it they cut them out i think they
were i think they were pretty boom
was this either those roasts were oh
yeah they cut them or they cut them
the newer ones you the newer ones were
blue
uh
you can get them on youtube and they
don't cut anything funny and then there
were some funny [ __ ] but foster brooks i
used to come out on dean martin's show
and the way he
he just was such a good actor at that
drunk part
uh he did that
[ __ ] throw it up got that hot [ __ ]
all alcoholics
[ __ ]
and you know like we we before specials
and before [ __ ]
comedy before cable we would watch
richard pryor was on the [ __ ]
partridge family george carlin was on
the [ __ ] the thomas the train [ __ ]
the [ __ ] conductor and really
all those guys were you know they all
found ways to heavy dippy weatherman
remember that maybe
weatherman that was garland very
straight
the seven words uh [ __ ]
all those guys [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
i liked woody allen
when i was a kid yeah
man
his writing was so good
all those guys my [ __ ] that
see and this is all i ever
in my car today i i don't listen to
music it's it's always a com i jump from
one comedy station with other on my on
like you know it was funny with flip
wilson remember him sure he was great
great actor you i think i think wilson
could say that he was uh um
what do you call or underrated as a
comedian he did his care he did
characters he was political
he had geraldine he had geraldine with
the
the and killer the boyfriend
you know the devil made me do it that
was all in t-shirts
all on on [ __ ] and
a funny dude man he was a funny dude
didn't really do a lot of movies but the
show worked
and his comedy worked and he was and he
was political smothers brothers
at that time heavy political
uh but
but uh flip wilson had everybody on
the old nbc back there where johnny was
like in that
they don't use it anymore
uh but the original
nbc in burbank
right there where they did uh
saffron and son chico on the man the
tonight show right across the hall from
from each other and they used the cpo
sharky
we did that don rickles uh
thing that john lannis did and and he
talked about
when
i think maybe don rickles hosted the
tonight show and he [ __ ] up
johnny's lighter
and then they went over to go see they
went across the hall to go see him and
then he one time he came back and you
know they would they would go into each
other's
other shows which was which was awesome
but yeah those were just down the hall
they were shooting down the hall
shooting down the hall they come in
there yeah i mean
amazing that back before vhs if you saw
the wizard of oz if you didn't see it
that one time it was on you couldn't
[ __ ] see it till the next yeah to the
next year till the next year not where
nobody owned any movies nobody
you know nobody had movies
so are you still you're still pretty
active in the clubs huh yeah i'm trying
i sometimes just don't feel like getting
out but i need to practice i'm not good
at like taking a month off like yeah in
the pandemic what did you do did you uh
wait my girlfriend and i would just
stayed up there people would bring us
food like in space suits yeah you know
yeah yeah yep that was weird it's like
we missed a year of our lives you know
but but you didn't you like you hadn't
really taken that that time off huh had
you ever taken like that much time i
don't know right
i remember with joe rogan they were
talking about it when it went out
because we were saying this is our last
set the first time i only did one set
and then left at like a couple of months
open it wasn't like that and that was
really weird i mean even the beginning
of of that that
when you would hear
because
i think people had it before
in january i thought some people they
might have had it they just thought it
was the flu or whatever but
at that point in february or march
uh where
it's almost two years where somebody
said we're looking at like april the
middle of april that is like the end of
may and you're like the [ __ ] end of
may it's march i'm not gonna make it to
the [ __ ] end of may and then it just
turned into
where everybody lived like that forever
yeah
the whole world not just oh yeah like
it's not it's not like you could go to
steven's steakhouse and be like
am i the only one here they were
[ __ ] places were closed yeah and
places that closed that
were
maybe
mom and pop stores that now you see them
they go away they're the ones that
really i think that the i think that
maybe they should need some assistance
from the government where if you lost
your mom-and-pop business because of the
pandemic like you shouldn't
be punished for yeah right you know
going out of business some of them just
never came back never came back it was
it was terrible and and helping each
other out the thing that you did with
your tacos
you know bring other businesses together
right it's been on the news dominoes
went and bought up a bunch of uh
flyer you know gift certificates from
other restaurants
and then we're sticking them in their
pizza boxes giving them away
and
they just had to go pick up instead of
paying the
delivery service whether it be doordash
or whatever the the rest of them are and
this was a way of giving business to the
other smaller restaurants in the area
and just trying to keep them all
together you know i would have never
thought of
ordering food to my house i could not
[ __ ] go get it and once i started
doing it that's great
i used to go get food i'll make the
[ __ ] come back and bring me a
straw if you can get it
you get why cook
do you why no
we get that is why cook uh
is it healthier well it's just more
expensive but you know you can get like
the really high the top of the line uh
morton's and stuff yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah white go look and see if you have
your places on white [ __ ] i was just i
was just at morton's uh saturday night
that's good to stevens now hey uh how
come you have your vietnam stuff on
it was raining it was ready to go postal
no no no it was raining this is a good
booney capsule
is that the one from there or no no this
is one what did you bring back from
vietnam i brought back my cat
i still
i still blame my wife i had a boonie cat
it was ugly dirty and we did everything
it was on my head all sweaty and we
should drink beer out any day
how about a [ __ ] hat you could drink
beer i brought it home
i i brought it home
and my wife hated it she hated it all
and she swears what was your
vietnam nickname
uh they called me g [ __ ]
when i was there g for gil [ __ ]
because i was mexican i love that [ __ ] i
was g [ __ ]
you know somebody gives you a nickname
it sticks with you somebody just the
other day
sent me a happy birthday through
instagram and it said happy birthday
beef squasher
[Laughter]
so so what happened so what happened to
it so
all of a sudden it's missing she hated i
said you threw it away she says no i
didn't i said you threw it away
and she swears to this day
she didn't throw it away it just went
missing
so i found uh one online not uh
i put the flight helmet on but after the
flight helmet
that was my
that was my cap and so it keeps the rain
off you and so it was raining over there
at the house and i got there so i just
yeah this rain is terrible isn't it
it hasn't rained for like two years
they're going [ __ ] rain again
wow
you know i think i think when you go
my [ __ ] car is too nice to be in the
[ __ ] rain
go tomorrow no but you know nobody wants
to go
first of all nobody knows how to drive
in the rain i know exactly it's a gilson
the oil comes up
on the
you know what i was on the i was on the
101 years ago and that
that's the asian dude was spinning out
and as he spun i could hear him go whoa
my windows down and he was in a toyota
van but the tires are like that
they're sk you know one of those [ __ ]
band and he and i said and he was going
in and i said all this [ __ ]
right here and he started a spin
and
he just went home
i thought oh no i wouldn't have told
anybody that [ __ ] i went down uh on a
motorcycle
it's a bit
i saw someone also drive off barham
threw the [ __ ] fencing onto the
[ __ ] 101.
if you're going across
barham into kawenga [ __ ]
[ __ ] dudes on the phone or whatever
i'll get him over
through the little retaining thing and
onto the
onto the freeway they put on his blinker
and changed lanes and kept going
down beat the gps by 10 i mean i went
down one time in the motorcycle because
of the oil i was slow
i was being very careful i came to a
corner and i turned and it was drizzling
and the oil come on the back tires
went right up man and so i just
i was able to stay stay up there where i
was wearing a levi jacket the buttons
were off
the top of my break uh oh cylinder uh
wore down a little on the street or in
the on in the street
and so but i but i made it okay it's
it's it's ugly
my wife today coming down here
she says are they still gonna have the
show you know it's raining outside i
said dear it's inside i mean come on
it's not going to affect it yes we're
going to have the show
and so i drive down here there was less
fewer cars on the
freeways today than on a regular day so
it was nice and easy i mean i wasn't
speeding and you could see you know i i
drive safe but i'm really a defensive
driver especially
in this stuff you know um
i like you know i i like led zeppelin
you know i like rock music when you look
at like van halen you know and you look
at those guys in there
in their prime you know with the wild
hair and
they each have their [ __ ] identity in
their clothes and
you look at like they almost look like
like they almost didn't exist you know
like a time that passed yeah and you
know you were at the comedy store when
robin williams was there
like and richard pryor would go in
regularly huh
yeah uh
jimmy walker letterman chandling
eddie murphy
i mean guys that you would think back
like then become larger than
not every one of them but richard i mean
richard
would be at the time i was here richard
was really pretty ill
all that time i didn't get to see him
really really bro on stage and
eddie murphy was
probably the same class right
yeah they're both richard was awesome
the store was a special
expect we had paulie in here
the story i liked yeah
he moved to did you only move to vegas
yeah yeah he moved to vegas yeah
which
you always thought he would be around
the store because you know of his mom
and
and everybody here they were smart they
made him start at the laugh factory
instead of starting to stop starting at
the store and getting ridiculed for you
know right your mother owns the place
big deal right
the coming store was a tough it was a
tough place to break in wasn't it
i was rocking i was really lucky i get
it the first time i got that i nailed it
right i go back to new york yeah how'd
you do like
great one time paid regular yeah i go
back a month later she didn't even
remember me at all wow
all this [ __ ] bragging it's going to
waste right
she was [ __ ] tough man oh wow
you know i was over there one time and
uh
they turned the light on
and then the crowd was like turn the
light off like and i go do it [ __ ]
what i do then the the piano player goes
keep going i turn the light off there
eddie cantor light the original room and
uh you get off and and i went over mitsy
shore and she goes where are you from
and i said i'm from uh you know san
fernando valley mission hills
and she goes and i quote why don't you
work the clubs there
for like a couple of years and then come
back
and um and i was like this leaning into
that at her table yeah yeah she was you
would lean in like this and say why
don't you go with it and then you're
like
[ __ ] crawl back
yeah buddy
mission hills for two years and she goes
there are no clubs in mission hills i go
on [ __ ] out
the [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] you know
like is that
michelle's with [ __ ] broadway you
know what do you have to do out there
what does she say if you ever got to go
back
once you've made
you're successful
you ever go i never went back
never saw her again i lost my act in 91.
carlos mancia saw it
and took it
and uh
i don't think i have the last time i
performed at the store was
[ __ ]
you went to the lab factory yeah i went
to the ice house and then i went to
fashion show and a little bit of the
improv but the improv was [ __ ] tough
man yeah that's a rough room i remember
that guy ken weinstock of course yeah so
ken weinstock you're doing this pair of
jokers
or a special i think we have a half hour
special
and tim allen for the [ __ ] home
improvement
all that [ __ ]
you're up next that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] leaves half the crowd
leaves i go up there you could hear
them [ __ ] doing the dishes in the
kitchen
and
i
nothing worked i mean i was just [ __ ]
i wasn't re i mean not who know i don't
know you can't go back but i wasn't
ready to follow a guy
that was on the number one show on tv
and then ken was there to just to look
at blocking
and the next day he called me he goes
you know
you know i think
we're gonna find somebody else you know
to do the show because i did so poorly
that he
didn't think that
i could
do good i guess i don't know
but it might have been a good thing yeah
he took it from wow but it might have
been it might have been
you know you don't think of it then but
i guess it was hard not it might have
been a a good lesson to it
to learn to because i was always really
very
structured
and then as i got more comfortable i
started to fill in the little bit of the
blanks but i never really wanted to go
up there and just wing it like paul
rodriguez was great
when it worked
when he'd go up there and start winning
because he had a great attitude and then
when it worked he was great and when it
didn't he was still funny because he was
like great at
self-deprecating stuff great great at it
so it still worked but
i didn't want to be like a hidden miss
like you were never hit and miss you
don't want to be a guy that
you know how am i going to do i don't
know how he's doing all right
where you could be pretty consistent i
think the only thing that brings comfort
in stand up is a little bit of being
[ __ ] consistent not down yeah
definitely yeah i remember listening to
uh i went to a function
some cop function and they hired
rudy moreno
to go up there and he went up there and
i was friends with rudy
and he got up there and he started doing
his bit and i'm dying laughing
nobody was laughing out there
and i was laughing and he knew it
he called me so many names after
because he was dying and i was laughing
because he was dying
because he was
he'd sit there nobody would laugh and
i'd ra
and he and it wasn't his fault they had
some tv celebrity
i won't mention his name but he went up
there
joe rico went on there i can't believe
we got it out of him yeah
joe rico introduced you to joe
he was being a newspaper yeah yeah he
was right
local newsman well joe rico introduced
him
but never got the crowd into it before
he introduced he said hey now we have a
comedian here rudolf
and so he didn't do much
so it was like being in a mexican
wedding there were people running around
people talking nobody's paying attention
to him and i'm his friend but i'm
laughing because he's dying
and then he stepped off and by this time
now people real oh there's entertainment
up there and he was followed by gilbert
esquivel
who
killed him everybody's laughing at him
and i walked out and and we see you
chick and [ __ ] you were laughing at me
because i was dying and it was funny and
he's we still talk about it to this day
those are tough gigs man
uh yeah you had some of those
yeah well especially corporate dates
i had them turn the mic off on me
and i'd go and go what's happening and
the manager booked me goes
and i go you know the car was ready for
us like we escaped with the money you
know i've had a few bad ones oh i was
doing uh i did i remember dan lundgren
was the attorney general uh-huh so up in
sacramento they they go they want you to
do this thing
so
before i go up there go we're just going
to do a little something before
it's a uh it's honoring all the officers
uh slain in the line of duty
and i'm like
what
is that what's funny about that yeah and
then i go it can't get [ __ ] worse
than this and i [ __ ] picture
a couple of all officers on like one oh
my goodness one frame of a picture and i
go i think that's
worse
because before those words and then they
go let's let's remind everybody of who
we're talking about that [ __ ] thing
comes down and there's like and i'm just
in the back going man i don't think are
you ready
i said no
i'm not ready that's tough
no way
i mean did you did you end up going out
yeah
let's bring that picture back down yeah
that's my name up there
i also died in the line of duty i mean i
don't think you know i'm not sure what i
would have done had i not
you know been blessed to have been a
a comedian i don't know
all the things i would have done right
yeah i mean
people say that to me because i'm inept
at everything except that
they go you're lucky you can't stand up
i said well stand up and teaching i'd
like to have fourth grade for a couple
years i like the kids but i hate getting
up
never that's never changed you know how
did you become how did you decide
anymore do you were a teacher yeah i
just got a job after uh college somebody
put in a word for me and
it was catholic school so i didn't have
to have a teaching degree you know i
loved it yeah i just you know the kids
in the morning banging on my car i'm
sleeping in there
the bell rung missed out rare
little black kids are calling me style
rap mr aubrey you're so nice you're not
white you are tying
yeah i loved it they still keep in touch
with me some of them oh man that's
awesome oh that's cool yeah and that's
that's the best you know you know
when you have uh when you have a cool
teacher man
i don't you know first of all
there are two things teachers probably
get
veterans
and teachers in this country
should be the highest paid and not you
know some teachers can't make ends meet
that's right
and and when i was in 10th grade in san
bernardino high there was he was a
tennis teacher that's got dick crawl
beard
hair boris tennis white's the [ __ ]
class all day
and he knew that i you know had trouble
speaking up and stuff and he would say
george do you mind taking these papers
down in the office and he kept me active
you know he kept me handing out papers
like and i remember by the time i was a
senior i could i could you know talk and
engage and stuff and then when i when we
were going to graduate i still remember
man i went to the room and i said hey
crow man thanks for
you know everything man for what you
what you've done for me these years and
you know and he's like you know george i
saw something in you man i knew that you
were like painfully shy and
i just tried to get you to be on your
feet you know and i was like well i mean
i'll never forget you man that's what i
did yeah self-esteem was the important
thing give them some self-esteem let
them laugh at themselves and
you know that
i mean i told them at the beginning of
the year like i said look i hate math i
got to try and teach it to you
i said i'm going to be with the dumb
kids and that laughing and
you know just
i tried different things for different
kids you know i said this one kid he
used to climb up me like a monkey
you look at me like the space like
and i go robert you can't
walk up your teacher
i can't i'm not going to bring you down
to this mother superior and tell her
that
until you know that you're that nuts
what am i supposed to what am i supposed
to do to this one kid i told him uh run
the church and i said
don't ask me any stupid questions we'll
go right to the gym one kid comes up to
me and they go mr mr
robert brains
he peed his pants like what the kid's
standing there crying he goes well you
said not to ask any questions but no not
for that
that's a stupid question
i still talk to him and his mother still
alive juicing
you know
i said you know i didn't mean him didn't
mean for him to do that she goes i know
you like the kid too much he would never
do that to him but he was taking you
know yeah yeah the literal thing
literally yeah yeah
i mean no it does make a difference you
say about teachers i went through a
leadership uh
school
for training it through the department
and you sat in groups and you had to
come up what does it take to be a leader
you know what are the
what are the uh
traits of a good leader and then in your
group come up with three leaders that
you think match all these traits so we
did it and after the class
the instructor comes up and he says
guild he says uh who'd you guys come up
with i said well we came up with uh
colin powell schwarzkopf and i don't
know the third one you know probably
washington i i forget who the third one
was
and he says were you happy with that i
said yeah they're they're good leaders
is there anybody else you missed i said
well personally
the wisest man i ever met
never known to this day was my dad
and
he said well why didn't you put your dad
in there i said well he had no formal
education he didn't have that but he was
the wisest man i've ever met here's why
we talked
and he says
that's the correct answer he says
your dad your parents
teachers
are great leaders because they instill
this stuff in you he says there's
nothing better to teach those are the
answers we're really looking for
he said would you talk about your dad
after i said no i can't he said do you
mind if i can if i will
you go for i can't because i'll get
emotional
and so he talked about it but teachers
do the same thing and the same thing
you're talking about how they come to
you and how your
teacher made an impact on your life they
are
leaders
infinitely wise and they're not don't
have don't need a i learned you don't
need a formal education we had a [ __ ]
crossing guard in elementary school
that we would give candy to
as we walked to school love this guy
and they put a light
there and they removed them as a
crossing guard
and
everybody he had a going away thing at
the auditorium
and
everybody
i still remember that that night
everybody was there the doors were open
because people couldn't
[ __ ] fit inside
and here's this dude up there and man
and you see what it impacts somebody
like that so it doesn't take everything
that i thought it took
you know who impacted your life why were
they leaders and he kept kids safe they
followed him they did this they did that
and i think you know now with i mean
listen i
i'd have never seen social media coming
like
the internet oh yeah maybe but social
stars suffer [ __ ] they become stars
and
it's all a [ __ ] facade of like i
don't even really look anymore but it's
all a facade of what people want to be
versus what they versus what they are
the guy you had on your show leo
the the marijuana no the one that does
all the tick tock or whatever oh yeah
yeah yeah
i mean
he
every day different people [ __ ]
did take talk of of me [ __ ] yeah
starting out the [ __ ] did it
like me looking for a car my car
he's like you know
oh
you know that [ __ ] dude
and uh my my daughter maya went to his
birthday party he has a [ __ ] house in
the hollywood hills it's like this
[ __ ]
is on tick tock and him and like five
other people are living in the [ __ ]
hollywood hills yeah it was it was
incredible and he started he had a
hundred dollars in his pocket when he
came over here to start this [ __ ] and
then he he did it and and he does and he
does good stuff i don't think you'll
find
that connection in those people like you
found a connection in a teacher
or in a [ __ ] crossing guard
or in somebody that
you could go to
and they would either calm you down on a
rough day fictional
yeah he is real yeah he is real where
all that [ __ ] is just you know uh
i mean i still listen i [ __ ] vote for
the animal if the animal attacks that
[ __ ] that has this [ __ ] head
in the you know he's doing the like in
florida they have those shows
he's a [ __ ] alligator the [ __ ]
alligator closes and i'm [ __ ] going
like that
i [ __ ] root for the animals now
because
they've taken enough [ __ ]
for so long i saw that bobby mirror
bobby bear senior the [ __ ] orangutans
in vegas they had a
noon show for like ten dollars
and we're after this show you go outside
it's bright and we come around the
corner there's a [ __ ] dude with a
long [ __ ] cane with his elephant
[Laughter]
[Music]
you come out of the show with [ __ ]
lights like there you go that was
[ __ ] amazing
[Music]
[ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of this
elephant and you're like wait a minute
what the [ __ ] chicken what did he do
he got on his three-point stance
but i mean you know i i'll go for the
i'll root for the [ __ ] animal now
because
they still test on
you know
vegas would you move to vegas i think i
would which i would have known i can't
no i can't deal with 110 115 degrees
yeah
i remember one time a nun told my mother
she said that
your son's so funny he could make a cat
laugh
that stuck with me
oh that's [ __ ] hilarious my eighth
grade night said to me i never met a boy
i didn't like until i met you
and she said and by the way i teach all
boys that's really hate yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome
that's [ __ ] awesome i remember both
of them clearly you know
i think you look the same as a kid as
you do now i think do you
same the face big nose no no huh but a
unique a unique girlfriend carries a
picture of me as a baby because you know
i don't know that's awesome
yeah but you were always [ __ ] awesome
dumb i mean thanks we hung out in denver
a few years ago what were you doing
there what was i doing there were at the
clubs i think we you were at a theater
and i was at a comedy club yeah we had a
couple drinks in the morning remember
yeah that's right yeah buck and dom is
awesome
thanks for coming in here oh thank you i
appreciate you brother i love you man
thank you love you too this was
it was great for me nice to meet you
thank you my pleasure
thank you in in the whole thing of
having a podcast
this is what i would
have a podcast for this doctor this is
great i think it's fun yeah it's just
great great and then uh dom anything to
plug you mentioned the podcast right you
do live from the laugh factory is your
podcast anything else yeah this is get
your tickets now because i'm at the
governor's comedy club in the beginning
of february and i'm telling you it's
like it's going to sound like hotcakes
i'm kidding it's not even up yet but
yeah i'm doing some clubs and uh
you know this i love this this is fun
you're right about talking oh everything
doesn't have to be a punchline but if
it's funny you know yeah i mean i mean i
would have never
really kind of i would have never really
done it really but
i think this is i don't think anybody's
ever seen me talk for anything more than
long five minutes but it's great see you
having fun with it you know yeah they
have people like you and guys that come
in there you know and
you know somebody wanted us to come you
don't you don't do we do you
no i don't i i just didn't like it
i always thought it should be legal
honestly nothing politically but i never
just heard of a marijuana fighting a bar
you know yeah
exactly and when he was you know we
talked about this all the time when he
was an officer
it was a felony to have the smallest
amount yeah on you a single joint would
have been a [ __ ] joint it just
doesn't those guys were in jail next to
rapists and child molesters come on it
didn't make sense didn't make sense to
me then yeah and i'm i'm no prude still
today i just you know i do whatever you
wanted it's pretty amazing man that what
the [ __ ] alcohol do i mean you know i've
i've drank
well i used to be a real heavy drinker
but what it does to a person and
especially all of the in getting in the
car yeah and driving or fighting and not
knowing you're fighting all the [ __ ]
that in families oh yeah it's the one
thing that can destroy your [ __ ] he
started drinking no i started drinking
it or in the car were like hey don't get
mean you're like [ __ ]
and then you look at you look at
weed and not
now he just sleeps early
i mean i'll tell you it really helped
rogan
because it calmed him down you know he
has three little girls he loves them but
that and the weed is what really turned
it around for him yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's awesome
there you go good stuff thanks for
coming out man thank you there you
go my friend
you